launching a new IP and launching a new
franchise would something like that
interest you to wield the power of
something like an MCU or something like
your Miller world would you go back if
you had that much power to to mash them
together you know we're sort of trying
to do it with M at the moment because we
have we've got Kingsman we have kickass
we have Ary we have two other things
we're making at the moment as well but
there has to be a reason to do it and it
has to be that everything is better with
them not just the gimmick I came up with
the of days of future past but I wanted
to do it third I said it's too early to
bring it together it's too big an event
we got to do a second one where we'll
bring there's cast a young Wolverine
let's have some fun here build out this
new X-Men universe and then number three
we bring them all together and dingdong
the studio was just saw dollar signs
when I gave them the idea and then went
phase two going straight to phase three
shortterm great longterm not so great
it's tempting to put all the ingredients
into a pot but they still got to have a
right balance otherwise you know I'm not
really that interested in having a I
don't
know a cheesecake flavored with steak in
[Music]
[Applause]
it this is that's a great question I am
Coy jandro we are here at the real
rejects I am sitting down with the man
who's given us Stardust layer K kickass
Kingsman and now Argy how you doing Mr
Von I'm very well how are you doing well
I I loved this film and I'm really
excited to sit down and talk to it I'm
also a giant comic book fan so I love
how much you love that medium and real
quick for those listening who don't know
the plot of it I'm just going to read
your IMDb logline to avoid spoilers
because there are many Argyle is about a
reclusive author named Ellie who writes
Espionage novels about a secret agent
and a global spy Syndicate who realizes
the plot of the new book she's writing
starts to mirror real world events all
in real time to me this really feels
like a graphic novel come to life and
you've done my personal favorite X-Men
film as well as as I mentioned Kingsman
and kickass in this new Zenith of comic
book films do you find it's more
comfortable to do stuff outside of the
big two or more things that are original
Ip or adapted from book IP that feel
like a graphic novel less scrutiny there
I just want to try and do things that
are you know are original and you know
when I was a kid Back to the Future Star
Wars Raiders the these are all new new
pieces of you know they became but they
weren't when they started um or weren't
wellknown IP I suppose they were IP
everything's IP um but I it's more of a
challenge but it's more rewarding now
that being said there are a few comic
book characters that if somebody rang up
said do you want to have a go with this
you know it' be a long hard debate of
the child and in inner child going yes
please I would love to make a Superman
movie um but at the same time when you
do these big
franchises the I'm not not worried about
the fans and and you know and and and
playing with with the responsibility of
these big characters that are loved but
I am worried about the studio
interference that start making you do
things that I know the fans aren't going
to like um yet you still have to do it
so it is a balancing act between between
the two but there are you know a few
characters that I think long that could
be dangled in front of me that I would
definitely um be hypnotized by but who
knows where it would end up I definitely
want to talk about Comics more later on
but I love what you mentioned about the
studio and I love particularly with this
film Universal agreed to only show the
first 28 minutes in the trailers and
that is an astronomical gift for this
film it allowed the shocks the surprises
and all those things but I love
threeyear descriptors for the film as I
was researching you're you described it
as a array of sunshine to escape the
world a blockbuster of the heart and a
wink and the perfect date movie and it's
somehow all of these and I'm wondering
with tones that are so disperate on
paper what was it like directing actors
in a film that has so many evolutions of
tones to keep them on track through the
narrative especially with like Bryce's
role or cranston's it's called editing
so on the you know on the day we just do
different takes we DT it up we DT it
down and then in the edit I made sure I
got choices with with you know for the
tonal balance because there's a lot of
really fun stuff that we cut out and
there's some really serious stuff that
we cut out and it was all just trying to
keep the balance when I say where it's
fun and I do say this and I mean it but
not silly now some people are going to
argue with that point very quickly but I
I do say I think it's Feelgood fun with
a heart and it's interesting watching
how people react or Zone in on other
things like a lot of people say oh my
God the action incredible and I go what
about the romance ah that
other people are like oh the romance is
great I what do you think of the action
like yeah it's okay but oh my God I love
the romance so it's it's it is
interesting how how when you have all
these these um ingredients some people
like salt some people like
sweet you've talked a lot about how uh
the crowdsourced audience are sometimes
more helpful than the studio notes and
the studios are really good at telling
you what's wrong but a lot of times the
audience is good at telling you what's
right when you're editing like you just
described it's so many different levels
how do you know which ones to read do
you just open up to a bigger crowd or
how do you try to play we do test
screenings with you know four 500 people
in the room and and it's interesting a
test screening half of it you don't even
need to read the note you just sit there
you feel it you know um and on this
movie the hardest thing to get right was
Clarity you know it was a complicated
plot and Landing twists and turns and we
did a shorter cut where because you know
and then people watch the movie and they
were like ah I can't cope with this it's
too Bang Bang the Twist and the turn so
then I went against what I'm used to
okay we're gonna have to put stuff back
in I've never done that in my life um
and then the movie gets slightly longer
but we realized a slightly longer movie
with Clarity feels shorter than a than a
shorter movie with confusion feels much
longer it's so the pacing thing was a
real real lesson to me on this one and
and and yeah some people still book
reading watch the movie saying oh my God
it's too fastpaced for me and I'm like
really gosh um but and some people
saying oh it's a little bit long but I'm
like trust me a little bit quicker you
you that it won it's not as satisfying
sometimes you know you have a three
course meal you got to enjoy each course
maybe have even a little bit of you know
what is it called a you know a pallet
cleanser with a sbet between each course
and then it's a perfect meal or you can
eat three cheeseburgers quickly and real
sick so it does feel like a lot of
different acts in one film and I really
like that it didn't have its traditional
structure and I think that's the benefit
of how you edited it and we have plenty
of three cheeseburger meals in theaters
uh but I also feel like The Meta
Narrative of this this film really suits
your sensibilities you've had a lot of
meta narratives throughout your career
so far but I'm wondering with that do
you visualize like Ellie in
pre-production when you're producing a
film or when you're writing a film do
you have that element we we you know the
way I work is you get the script as good
as possible then I shot list the script
not storyboard I just go through every
scene knowing I need this I need that
and then I go to storyboard artists for
because sometimes I find it weird you go
to some movies and they storyboard the
drama and I'm like really this and that
I mean do you really have to storyboard
that but so we we only storyboard and
stunt this the complicated stuff that no
one can get their head round so when I'm
saying we're going to do dancing and
with smoke or oil skating all that stuff
you gotta you know everyone's like what
are you talking about and and then we
had to and and again the the idea of
doing double action no one could I was
like no it's going to be cool they're
going to Blink we're going to have
exactly the same fight choreography but
done in a certain interpretation of
Scrappy versus a superstar so that's the
stuff that you have to you know really
make crystal clear for people to follow
but the casting as well and all these
characters is in my
head you know I'm like script first
start you know short listing and
storyboarding while casting and once you
got the right cast and the right
storyboard and the right script and the
stunt visors then we go make the movie I
we do all that with a much smaller crew
because you don't need that many people
to do that but there crew come aboard
the thousands of other people they have
a very very clear road map to follow and
then the directing wise uh you know the
getting through that pre-production very
specifically directing this there's a
lot of elements without giving too much
away that are that are uh the director
has to navigate having their actor look
to camera directly like down the lens
after years of actors not being able to
do that how do you navigate that almost
fourth wall break that's so direct
without a series of bloopers or having
to tweak the edit again a lot of magic
happens in the edit and there's a lot of
trust I have to trust my actors and they
have to trust me and and I always say
look we can we just let's just try it if
it doesn't work we'll cut it out but if
we don't try it we can't put it in Fair
yeah and the actors you have here are
all so well versed in so many different
mediums and genres it really plays
getting to see them do stuff against
type and for type depending on the
tropes you're playing with uh and and
speaking of tropes playing with the Spy
drama is so important to you and I know
how much you love Bond and I know how
much you love working with guy Richie on
on spy films but here there's so much
research into spy operations and certain
spy lore is that something you did extra
or new research for for Ellie or is that
all stuff you had in your back pocket I
had it in my back pocket but I had to
dust it off and just remind myself of
facts and and but I I I obviously love
the world of
Espionage so it's instinctive to me and
if you're playing in a field that I've
been interested in since I was seven
years old um it's just fun I'm you I'm
playing like I was saying if you ask me
to to make War and Peace you know I'd
have to go read the bloody thing and it
looks long and it'll probably take me a
long time and I'll probably forget I
prob you know I don't think Warren peace
and I would be a good combination I
haven't even read it so I don't know but
imagine that that because you know but
meaning if you do what you love they you
know to quote Sam rock well if you do
what you love you never do a day's work
in in in your life and perfect tangent
for me for Sam Rockwell man I he's one
of my favorite actors alive he is so
interestingly Char charismatic like the
way he operates in a frame and the
dancing here is maybe my favorite Sam
Rockwell dancing which is the highest
praise I can give a film what came first
the action set pieces or the casting of
Sam Rockwell did you develop which
developed first uh the the action set
pieces were already written in my mind
and then I thought well who could do the
dancing Sam Rockwell um comes to mind
and you know very quickly and Sam Sam's
very brave and sort of you know he's
he's like a he's a bolt of energy when
he comes on with ideas and enthusiasm so
the two of us could be a pretty D if we
did an R-rated movie together we'd
probably end up doing n becoming nc7
just by default because it we would
definitely it was quite interesting I
had you know it was like um being an
animal house I I had Jason FS a little
angel on my shoulder here and I had Sam
Rockwell as the devil and every day the
two of them were saying certain things
to me and I was like wait which which
route am I going to go how do I land in
this cut for Universal if I've got this
man here yeah is he easier to direct
action with because he's so used to his
body and so comfortable in it he was
surprising um how fit and he's a very
good boxer and he you know and he
trained so hard to play Bob fosy he was
a pleasant surprise how good he was
actually you've talked about how he can
walk in a room and be a lot more
Incognito than a Henry caval or a Brad
Pit and how that worked for this kind of
spy story especially some of the action
you talked about at the top the innercut
action scenes when you cast both of them
was it their Mutual like unflappable
confidence that you thought would mirror
each other well or what did you see with
them as a pair for chemistry they again
it was it was like the perfect sweet and
sour um that you know you know we have
Bryce in the middle as the best filet of
chicken or ve whatever it's going to be
and I needed sweet and sour sauce to
make it delicious and that's they are I
love how in every scenario Sam rockwells
the devil sour some element of chaos the
hair in this film uh has been talked
about since we saw our first poster
since we saw the first trailer and and
to be vague without giving anything as
we get into the film but was the
distinctive Hair Choice an element that
would allow us to have some of the
twists be uh elaborated on later on was
that an early pre-production decision to
have some of those flat top Cuts yeah no
I wanted to try and create an icon when
there wasn't an icon and so I had to
give him a strong look so you'd go hey
what's that and the fact fact we could
do a poster of an unknown spy a picture
from behind with just a flat top and
everyone's going hey what's that what's
the flat top so it got he became a mini
icon overnight and I didn't have any
enough well much screen time to get our
girl feeling like a a spy that's been
around in the in our universe for a long
time and and is a famous spy you know
it's so that's why I thought we'll give
him said let's just give him flat top
and a Nero jacket and that's all he
wears so in the movie you see him he's
always flat top and near a jacket now in
the real world if that was your look as
a spy pretty dumb you know you're going
to you walk in the room everyone's going
to notice the guy with the flat top and
whether he's you know in the movie he
wears Nero pinstriped velvet you know
he's always that's his that's his Vibe
like you know Kingsman is double
breasted suits and glasses and an
umbrella Aral is black top nearo color
I've heard you talk about wardrobe being
so important to characters and I love
this perspective on iconic imagery and
how important that is and obviously
Comics Wolverine's mutton chops are as
important as anything but when you got a
wardrobe that's that iconic and that
important how do you develop it to have
it be so immediately registerable to all
audiences do you have a certain costume
designer you like working with do you
like looking at source material like how
do you develop that it depends I've sort
of got I've been doing this for a long
time so when I see characters I'm always
trying to just you know create icons so
you know I have all the things that
influence me so so male characters I'm
pretty comfortable and I I come to you
know and meet the costume designer and
say this is the look I want and then
they go off and develop it uh and then
on the female side I'm not as strong um
and that's where I have my lovely wife
who she goes off and and helps me um
because I'm not as good as dresses as I
am with suits Fair uh and the iconic
haircut again being something that we
saw so early on there's another very
iconic haircut in this film and I'm
going to be as vague as possible but it
is specifically on a man uh that is
known for other haircuts and it is very
much so a 90s Superman haircut to me um
was that something that you drew from
that iconic era of Superman or was that
are we talking about mullet man we are
yes yes yeah so I just think we got flat
top man and then we have mullet man and
and all I know look look at this in
screenshot of like I don't know 20
seconds or something we've suddenly got
two icons that you can discuss and
that's what I'm talking that's my job to
try and create you know kickass you can
a green wet I think it's green I'm color
blind but I think it was a green wet it
yeah yeah um it branding and and it's
very important to me and I think in this
world the stronger The Branding the more
chance you're going to get
noticed seeing mullet man on that man
made me very happy as a comic fan I I'm
glad it was uh it it felt right after
all these years well there you go thank
you so going back a bit speaking of
caval in the the era of Stardust he is a
total unknown to to most American
audiences as is Charlie Cox and I know
you're a big comic book fan how was it
for you from the outside to see one of
your guys become the Man of Steel and
another one become The Man Without Fear
it's sort of weirdly satisfying in an
odd way it's just not it's it's it's
it's uh every time I've worked with
someone or Tom Hardy becoming Venom uh
Daniel Craig becoming Bond um I'm sure
there's other you know Taylor Johnson's
Craven now uh you know yeah Aaron is
Craven yeah I me I'm sure there's other
I mean that's what so odd I'm trying to
go through the actors I've worked with
to seeing them how they come these sort
of icons that I've Loved or superheroes
or spies so it's weird it's also a bit
of a bugger because then when I watch
the movies it's not quite as magical for
me because I know deep down that Daniel
Craig isn't really James Bond or um
Charlie cany um so um so that's a little
bit odd you know the magic is harder and
but they're all brilliant at what they
do and and it's um it's a lovely it's
and it's really nice when you work with
actors who are starting their career and
they're nervous and then you see them
becoming these Mega stars and having
such success um you just well done them
and and Pedro his his last few years
after Pedro yeah that was like that by
the way when when we cast Pedro in um in
the kingsman's gold golden was called
kingsman the golden service that's how
tied I am the go what is it golden
circle circle um and when I um you know
when I gave Pedro the part he was so
like no I really got the part he was so
humble about it and this guy had been
working so hard for so long and I
couldn't understand it when I I said I
said this guy is a movie star this guy's
a fantastic actor he looks great and and
I remember saying when you do this movie
you I I knew he he would just be a
rocket for him and um and it's great
he's a sweet sweet man and it shows in
the work to see how much each of these
actors has to do in these performances
because you are making them icons you
are making them their own IP as we
discussed at the top and I I remember
hearing about like Daniel kuuya and and
tan and these finalists for Kingsmen and
how everyone kind of launched from that
point was there ever a moment when you
were making Kingsmen that you took a
step back or even layer cake going back
further where you thought like oh this
is the next wave of movie star this is
the next set of these people and even
beyond the superhero IP is there a sense
of like family where you guys keep in
touch with these big
announcements I remember Daniel on on
the lir cake just looking through the
camera there's an odd thing with movie
stars or even musical with j j leap as
an example and um even just with Boy
George we worked with him on on electric
energy on this and you look through the
cam camera and a star I don't know how
to exp the lens sort of melts around
them or they melt into the lens I don't
know what it is but it is so obvious
right I mean I'm not some Maestro that
sees things that nobody else can we all
see it you know that's why they become a
star we're all looking at them in the
same way and it's not necessarily they
being goodlooking right as well that's a
real you know like Jean Wilder uh for
example the camera melted on him it's
there is a Charis there's a something
and I there I say there is an X Factor
there is something a person has that the
camera or the microphone or the stage
wherever they go on whether they're a
chef whether they're an artist just
something that unknown happens and it's
magical and it's an Alchemy like no
other um and so when I cast these people
I'm just seeing it for what it is it's
not me it's just I'm just capturing what
they are oozing um and some of them you
know and so I'm not really that
surprised I'm I'm sort of I'm just proud
of them and having being a tiny part of
their journey I I do want to talk about
casting a bit later on because there is
so much in the world of casting right
now as we're seeing I just love that
comic book films are beyond the medium
now and they're becoming their own thing
and and making something like Argyle
launching a new IP and launching a new
franchise but uh the world of kickass
has its own spin in IP because did you
read uh Mark Miller's new big game event
that just happened big game event yeah
so he just concluded um basically all of
his worlds he just put them all together
so Nemesis kickass Kingsman all came
back together in an Avengers esque event
and he called it big game so basically
he made his phase one and brought your
guys from Kingsman to your guys from
kickass and and mesh them together in a
fascinating way and I was wondering if
you could get back into that world did
that would something like that interest
you to wield the power of something like
an MCU or something like your Miller
world would you go back if you had that
much power to to mash them together um
yeah Never Say Never I mean I I you know
we're sort of trying to do it with MV at
the moment because we have we've got
Kingsman we have kickass we have Ary we
have two other things we're making at
the moment as well and so we we're
getting these characters but there has
to be a reason to do it and it has to be
that everything is better with them not
just the gimmick and then it's you you
you do great I I had this argument on um
Days of Future Past because I you know
did first class and then I came up with
the idea of Days of Future Past and then
but I wanted to do it third I said it's
too early to bring it together it's too
big an event we got to do a second one
where we'll bring let's cast a young
Wolverine let's have some fun here build
up the build out this new X-Men universe
and then number three we bring them all
together and ding dong the studio was
just saw dollar signs when I gave them
the idea and then went number phase
two we're going straight to phase three
which I thought was you know shortterm
great longterm not so great um it's
tempting to put all the ingredients into
a pot but they still got to have a right
balance otherwise you know I'm not
really that interested in having a I
don't know
a cheesecake flavored with steak in
it yeah back to the three cheeseburgers
there really should be an Atif in
between I I love that you brought up
Days of Future Past because I really do
think it's something that had the good
source and then it kind of like kitty
Pride had power she didn't have and
there were choices made that that did
feel like it was serving itself instead
of serving The Narrative is there any
X-Men story you would love to see
adapted now that we're bringing the
mutants into the MCU as a comic fan just
from the outside is there a story line
you'd love to see on screen I'm going to
say something b a little bit
controversial but one of my favorite
storylines which I was involved with was
X3 and the Cure and I didn't think and
that I found fascinating so if I was
asked you I I'd love to have done do
that properly because I did think the
idea of to be cured of something
amazing was and now with what happened
with you know the vaccine and covid and
and mass vaccinations comp and I thought
that plotline um was it Bendis no who
did that uh think it was Weeden on
astonishing we it was Weeden yeah the
first astonishing X-Men Arc I believe it
was that c Arc yeah I think it was Josh
yeah Weeden said that that would be
something I'd like to I think with the
modern world could be a very powerful
story line it's impossibly topical and I
and I do think it it lends itself to the
commentaries on like Prejudice and and
obviously the inherent bigotry in the
X-Men when you were developing X-Men um
and you had all the the studio rumbly
jumbly was there ever anyone you put
forth as a casting idea since casting is
so important to you we didn't get to see
or is there anyone that you'd love to
see as an X-Men rumbly jumbly I will
quote you for that that'll be my new
that's my new word of the day
um let me just think about that um no I
sort of got everybody I wanted I mean it
all it it all fell into place um I had
to fight very hard to cast Jennifer
Lawrence ironically and I did have a
problem casting fast Bender because the
poor guy the mustache and the auditions
because he was playing I think
Kung um and the studio kept saying well
we don't like his mustache and I was
like you know there's a thing go a ra
and movie we will get rid of it and
they're like yeah but that mustach I
like stop talking about the mustache
this guy is brilliant um so so as I said
I fought for who I wanted so you know I
I I I think the casting was pretty damn
good in that film yeah I mean Lucas Till
Zoe kravit seeing a lot of people again
that have now become household names
from that cast at and to me first class
feels the most like an X-Men movie not a
mutant movie like the the heart of what
the X-Men is is there uh as they bring
the X-Men into the MCU and and you
following as a fan of the comic books is
there anything you'd love to see the MCU
transition into using the element of the
fox characters like the Fantastic 4 or
the MCU would you like to see them
interacting or would you like to see it
a little off sides I would like to see I
I think why the MCU worked so well they
were disciplined at the beginning keep
the cat keep these characters separate
get you know get have one or two movies
and then you that's why I didn't think
Justice League worked because they just
slapped all these characters together
but we hadn't spent enough time with
them to really enjoy them coming
together and that's why the Avengers
were so great because we'd had enough
individual movies and then and you it
was so you know Kevin feige was a master
how he did that so if I was doing it I'd
say fan for X-Men make them right so set
it up do one or two movies of both and
then slowly start letting the tentacles
go that's what I would do I I totally
agree and it always feels like the X-Men
are just outside of New York for a
reason like Upstate Westchester
intentionally is over there is there
anything that would lure you back to MCU
anything with like Kevin figer anyone
running it over there that would call to
you enough I know I don't want to give
anything away but like just as a fan of
the comics a character you'd like to
play with um yeah if they called me up
and said I mean look I love that
universe so um and I Kevin so yeah I
would never say never they he called me
up and said look we want to like I don't
know Iron Man you know originally I
wanted to do Iron Man about 22 years ago
when it was at new line and I found the
script and I was like this is the future
I want to make Iron Man and everyone
said you're just crazy No One's Gonna
it's the dumbest title and what a guy a
rich guy builds a superhero Iron costume
never going to work so um you know so so
if I read you know never say never
well before we get out of here the DC
Universe is also jumping again it's
starting in its own way and I know how
much respect you have for gun and
saffron uh those announcements for Comic
fans were insane some of the stuff they
said I'm shocked they're making even in
this age of superhero was there a
certain announcement that you are most
excited to see if not work on well
Millie Alcock a Supergirl was I met with
her again eight months ago I saw saw her
in in House of dragon went this is a
future star so we met there's a project
I I I thought should be grateful and she
turned me down which I was like okay
that's she's um that's okay fair enough
um um and I'm not surprised she's now
going to become become Supergirl she's
brilliant she's absolutely brilliant is
there anyone you've met with in in all
your years that you could see off the
top of your head as someone with the DCU
or MCU with the history of your casting
these people that feel like movie stars
through the lens is there anyone that
hasn't yet hit that Tipping Point
Taran
Edon yeah I and I know everybody says
him is Wolverine but I I personally he's
he doesn't look like he smells bad
enough oh he
does perfect that was my only issue I
want a wolverine that looks like the
peanuts on the bar are the smell that he
has um so before we get out of here I
also know your love of James Bond is
profound and both you and Henry caval
have been almost bond in your own ways
with Henry's insane streak of almost
Cullen almost Bond and now the Superman
chaos was there a moment when making
this it felt like there was a bit of of
karma for you get it to make your your
spy Thriller through Argy with someone
we've all wanted as bond for so long
yeah I wouldn't say it's karma I just
say it was a the right it was the Stars
you know aligning correctly um and it
was fun and um I still think if Henry if
they chose Henry to be Bond they they
they it will do very very well I think
Henry will make it his own vehicle but
he's so in Fleming wrote Henry caval as
you know or Henry C you know I don't
know whether Henry caval read Bond when
he was a kid and just molded himself on
that because he he as close to a real
life Bond as anyone I've ever met and it
absolutely plays and I hope I mean have
10 years down the line the H you Kingdom
Come and maybe you can bring him back
over there too because I'd love to see
it there's a lot of that element here is
there anything you'd love to do with
Henry next or any of this cast because I
love your work with Sam and Bryce here
is incredible I would love to work with
them again we have ideas we've discussed
it but we need people to see this movie
first of all if if arar works then
there's going to be a lot more surprises
and fun to come I love that this is book
four and I love that you want to do book
one next I love that Ellie is a real
author there's so many elements of this
that I can't wait to understand How Deep
The Meta Rabbit Hole goes but most of
all I really appreciate all your work
man and your work with guy Richie
producing snatch got me interested in
how films are made so I really
appreciate everything you've done and
your love
Comics is also so wonderful to see so
thank you so much man well thank you for
your time I appreciate it have a great
one